Everything is horrible!
What makes you say that?
It's just this general
feeling I always have.
Yeah, I feel that way too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's New Year, y'all, a time
when we all tend to take stock
in ourselves and
the world around us.
It's also the time of year
when I consume the most media,
since I'm pretty much stuck
on my grandma's living room
couch watching TV,
mostly under duress.
It's really easy to think, based
on our introspective New Year's
mindset and all the news around
us, with the wars and the crime
and the disease and the
environmental destruction
and the oppressive governments
watching us, and the drones--
Anthony, I'm going
to need you to take
a deep breath in and out.
Sorry, it is just really easy
to get caught up in that stuff.
But here's the thing.
It is genuinely the best time
in the history of the world
to be alive.
And it actually
keeps getting better,
especially when you realize
how short of a period of time
that we've been around, and
just how long humans have been
struggling against the elements.
True.
We hear a lot of stuff about
epidemics and mortality rates
in developing nations.
But since 1950, the infant
and child mortality rate
has gone down in every
single country in the world
in every income bracket,
every single one.
And the average life
span in the world
has gone from 47 to 70
years old in that time.
In the 1850's in
England, pretty much
the easiest place to live
on Earth at the time,
the average person
only lived to be 40.
So we've doubled that.
And there's still a lot
do to combat disease,
but this is still a huge gain.
And hunger is also
in a huge decline.
We're talking about 925 million
people living in hunger today,
as opposed to 958
million in 1970.
And that might seem like
a really small difference,
but the population
then was 3.7 billion,
and now it is 7 billion.
So that means we went from
having 25% of the world
not having enough
to eat to 13% now.
We dropped hunger by half.
We're even decimating poverty.
We hear a lot about
recessions and unemployment.
But 30 years ago,
40% of the world
was living on less
than $1.25 a day.
In 2010, that number
dropped to 14%.
Murder and violent
crime is dropping too.
Look, in the Middle Ages,
there was about 15% chance
that somebody was
going to murder you.
That was the deal.
You get born, you get an axe
to the face, and then you die.
In the 20th century, even
with both world wars,
violent death was down to 3%.
13 years into 21st century,
and we're down to 0.003%.
Still early.
I'm optimistic.
Yeah.
Well, those aren't just
some pretty solid numbers.
These are feel good numbers.
So why do we feel so bad?
Part of it is that,
hey, we weren't
around hundreds of years ago.
We're looking at such a
narrow picture of things.
And there's also the
problem of media saturation.
We know about everything
that's going on everywhere all
the time right now.
And the media tends to
focus on the negative.
A study done on the
content of Time Magazine
over a 30-year period showed
that 73% of those stories
were about violent crime, but
only 10% of the total crimes
reported to the police during
that same time were actually
violent.
It contributes to something that
mass media researcher George
Gerbner called Mean
World Syndrome.
That's a good name.
The media focuses
on the negative.
We only see the negative.
We only know the negative.
You can also call it the
Availability Heuristic.
You are more likely to
believe that the world matches
the available information
that's already in your head.
Right.
So you have to fill your
head with a more rounded view
of everything.
Dig down and find
the real information
and the good news
that's out there.
But don't think that we're just
glossing over all the work that
still needs to be done.
We know that there
are things to fix.
Just don't forget that
we're working on fixing them
while you're reading about
how to tear them apart.
When the world looks
bleak, you just
remember what DNews told you.
You are so much more unlikely
to get an axe in the face
than you once were.
So on that note, what's your
good news for 2014, guys?
Let us know down below and
subscribe for more good news.
I can't think of
a single person I
know who's gotten hit
in the face with an axe.
Me neither.
I did once in Scouts.
Why did you have to
go ruin it, Trace?